[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROB DODSON: Thank you
all for coming out today.
Quickly, before I
start, I just want
to point out that today is
Global Accessibility Awareness
Day, May 18th.
So thank you all for
coming out today.
And if you want to use the #GAAD
hashtag as you are tweeting
and things like that, that
would be very awesome.
So yeah, my name is Rob Dodson.
I'm a developer advocate
on the Chrome team,
and today I'm
going to be talking
about accessibility for teams.
So this talk came about
because, I guess kind of
at the beginning
of the quarter, I
had a partner reach out to me.
And they were like,
hey, Rob, our team
is getting started
with accessibility
and kind of wondering if I
had any material to help them
get ramped up and get started.
And I was like, oh, yeah, sure.
And I sent them an email
with a front-end developer
course that I put together
with a teammate of mine.
And I sent them some automated
build tools and things
like that.
And they followed
up a few days later,
and they were like, hey,
thanks, that was really helpful,
but like, what about
your designers?
And what about your
project managers
and everybody else on the team?
Do you have them
just do this course,
or how are you teaching
the rest of the folks
about accessibility?
And it made me stop for a second
and realize that, oftentimes,
when we're talking
about accessibility,
it's easy to get really
laser-focused on one
particular discipline or another
and only talk about, hey,
here's what developers
need to know, or hey,
here's what designers
need to know.
But really, accessibility
is a team effort.
No one person is responsible
for the overall design
and experience and
implementation for a site.
And accessibility touches
all of these things.
So every person on
the team has some role
to play in the process
of making the experience
accessible and usable by
as many folks as possible.
And so what I wanted
to do today was just
go through three of the key
stakeholders in the creation
of a project and discuss
some of the action items
that I think each of
these folks can undertake
and incorporate
into their process
to make sure that accessibility
is a top line item for them.
It's always on their
radar as they're working.
So I want to start off by
talking about the project
manager role.
And I think the overriding
goal for a project
manager in any project is
just to kind of make sure
that accessibility
is incorporated
into the major milestones
as folks are staging builds,
as designers are showing
comps, and as we're
moving through the process
of shipping our product,
that we're always
thinking about it,
that it's always on our radar,
and we're asking ourselves
things like, where
can we be improving?
How do we avoid regressing
and things like that?
How do we check where
we currently are
and how well we're doing?
And so I wanted to come
up with a few key items
that I think the
project manager needs
to keep in mind as they're
working through their process.
So I'm going to go through
each of these in more detail.
But from a high
level, as a PM, I'd
want to make sure that my
team is receiving training,
that I'm identifying
the critical user
journeys in my app,
I'm incorporating
some sort of accessibility
checklist into our process,
and I'm evaluating the
product with user studies
if I have that opportunity.
So let's dive into these
in more detail, starting
with that first one-- making
sure everyone on your team
receives training.
Now, I have done
projects before where
I have been the quote-unquote
"accessibility owner," meaning
I was the only person
who had been trained
or was versed in it at all.
And that's a really
tough position
to be in, because when you're
the only person working on it,
you kind of have to keep
an eye on everybody, right?
And it's very, very
difficult, because it's
going to often feel like
the whole team is sort
of racing ahead, implementing
features and shipping stuff,
and you're just trying to
run behind them and throw
some fixes over their shoulder
and hope that some things land.
So I think it's good to have
an accessibility champion,
or someone who's
driving that work.
But I also think it's really
important to make sure
that everyone on the team has
some training in this area
and has some
fundamentals established.
To give you an
analogy, we would never
say, hey, everybody on
the team, you can all
write whatever code you want,
and Lisa will make it run fast.
Right?
We would never treat,
like, performance that way,
but oftentimes we do treat
accessibility that way.
It's just that one person's job.
And it doesn't really
work well that way.
So there's a lot
of free resources
out there for training your
team up on accessibility.
Myself and a teammate
named Alice Boxhall,
we put together
a Udacity course.
So this is a free
online multi-week course
to get any front-end
developer up and running.
We cover topics like focus,
built-in semantics, ARIA,
accessible styling
with CSS, a little bit
of tooling and testing in there.
We also have taken all of
this material and put it
on developers.google.com/web
in written format,
so if you prefer something
you can search around,
this is a live doc set.
We're always updating it.
So we also have new guides that
we publish up there as well.
And for your designers, we've
also got the Material Design
Accessibility Guidelines.
I really like this document,
because it has a lot
of examples of dos and don'ts
and suggestions on how you can
improve the accessibility from
a visual standpoint in your app.
So that's just some resources
that you can give to your team.
And what I would
encourage you to do
is make sure that your team
has time during the work week
to learn this, right?
Don't just send them
off and be like,
hey, learn this
on your free time.
Carve out some time at
the beginning of a project
to go through this training, and
make sure everyone's on board.
The next thing I
would suggest is,
as you're starting off your
app, identify the critical user
journeys in your experience.
So this is going to
help you kind of scope
the work ahead, right?
And to give you an example,
a critical or a primary user
journey is going to be
something like a basic task
that every user is going
to have to perform in order
to use your app.
Sort of a critical
thing, like if you're
building an e-commerce
site, that the user can add
an item to their shopping cart.
That's something everybody's got
to do it in order to even use
the experience, right?
So you want to identify
these primary user journeys.
And you can also identify your
secondary user journeys, things
that might be infrequently
performed by everyday users,
stuff that maybe only power
users are going to do,
like being able to change your
avatar in the Settings menu
or something like that.
Once you have these primary and
secondary user journeys figured
out, then you can actually start
to incorporate an accessibility
checklist-- and I'll actually
show a few examples of this
in a second--
and start to kind of like us
see how your user journeys apply
to that checklist.
So the nice thing about
putting in a checklist
is if you're retrofitting
accessibility
onto a current site, using
a checklist will allow
you to sort of audit
where you currently are,
triage what work
needs to be done.
If you're starting
a new project,
then you can incorporate
that checklist early
into your process and
make sure, as you're
going through milestones,
that you're doing
reviews against that checklist.
So some example
checklists-- there
is a wedding checklist for
WCAG 2.0 A. This is primarily
geared towards web
developers, but it's
a really nice distillation
of the WCAG guidelines
in an easy-to-follow guide.
You can just go through and
check those off real fast.
If you prefer something
that's split up by discipline,
the folks at Vox Media have also
produced a similar checklist.
So this one, it's bucketed
by the different roles
on the team.
So here's what your
designer would be doing,
here's what your QA
staff would be doing,
here's what your editorial
folks will be doing.
Either one of these is a great
choice for self-assessment
of your project.
There's other ones out there.
If you just Google
"accessibility checklist,"
there's a number of them.
I would suggest,
just find whichever
one fits your work style best.
And then once you've
got that checklist,
you can start to apply
it to those user journeys
that you've identified.
So by identifying
these user journeys,
applying the
checklist to them, we
can start to get
really, really tactical
about our accessibility work.
So something that I've seen
teams do before is they'll
actually build a matrix.
And they'll have their
primary use cases as rows,
and their secondary
use cases as rows,
and then those checklist
items as columns.
So primary user journey--
a user can add an item
to their shopping cart.
OK, there's a lot of
steps involved there.
For all of those steps
along that journey,
can we assert that we
have good color contrast,
that our controls are
labeled, and so on and so on?
And so this way, you can be
really tactical about it.
You can actually start
to give yourself goals.
You can say, all
right, by Q2 of 2017,
all of our basic
accessibility checks
will pass for primary user
journeys, and things like that.
So you actually score
your work and figure out
if you're making progress
or if you're regressing.
And I would encourage
you to don't just
do this checklist once at
the beginning of the project
and forget about it.
Make sure you're
incorporating it
into all the major milestones.
So when you're seeing builds
from your developers or designs
from your designer, run through
that checklist with your QA
team and say, all right,
cool, did we make progress?
Did we regress?
Do we need to
improve some things
before we launch this build?
And that'll help you stay on
top of your overall progress.
And then finally, I would
say, if you're retrofitting--
or, sorry, if you have
the opportunity to,
incorporate some user
studies into your process.
Sit down with folks who maybe
use assistive technology.
If you're retrofitting
accessibility onto an existing
project, this will help you
identify some critical pain
points for some of those users.
If you're starting
a new project,
then it's good because you
can start doing these user
journeys early with
your prototypes,
and you're going to
avoid having to redo work
later down the line when someone
actually uses it and says,
oh, maybe this thing doesn't
work as well as we think.
I think it's entirely
possible to make
something that is technically
accessible, but not very
usable.
And so sitting down and doing
some actual user journeys
will help you identify
those situations.
And that way, you can
catch those problems early,
and you don't have to avoid
redoing that work over
and over.
So yeah, these are
the top-line items
that I would encourage
every project manager just
to have in their back
pocket as they're
thinking about how they can
incorporate accessibility
into their process a bit more.
Moving on, I want to talk
about the UX designer.
So I think that the
challenge for UX
is that we tend to design
using our own biases.
And so if you don't have a
disability or impairment,
you don't have a colleague with
a disability or impairment,
then it's easy to
forget that you
might be designing in a bubble.
And so you want to ask
yourself, as you're designing,
who is my design excluding?
And work through creating
different personas--
folks who would see and
experience the world
differently from you--
and try and figure out,
how would these users
engage with my experience?
It's also important to remember
that our bodies are not static.
We're constantly
changing all the time.
As we age, we may
develop disabilities
related to vision,
hearing, range of motion.
I saw a stat recently
that said, by 2050,
around two billion people
will be over the age of 60.
And I'm going to
imagine, they're
going to want to still
use the internet,
and they're going to
still use their phones
and whatever devices
we're using in 2050,
but vision, range of motion
might not be what it is today.
So keep in mind
that we're changing
for the constant evolving
and changing human body
and human experience.
And also understand
that our context is also
always changing.
We take our computers
with us now.
They're in our pocket.
And so we're not always using
them in ideal scenarios.
You might be using your phone
outside on a very bright
sunny day like today, and you
might have a difficult time
reading that screen.
It might be useful for it to
have some additional contrast.
So there are many reasons why
you might be situationally
or temporarily impaired.
And when we incorporate
that into our design process
and we design
inclusively, we end up
making a more satisfying
experience for many more users.
So these are the key items
that I would want a designer
to keep in mind as they are
going through their process--
making sure that they've
got good color contrast,
that tab order is identified--
and we'll talk about what that
means in just a sec--
that their controls
have good labels,
and that you've got multiple
ways to interact with your UI.
So let's dive into these
in more detail, starting
with color contrast,
because this is a big one.
I see a lot of sites
struggling with this.
So the way that we
measure contrast
is in terms of luminance.
We're doing a comparison
between the foreground
and the background color.
And at a minimum, we
want a contrast ratio
of about 4.5 to 1
for smaller text.
So this is text that's smaller
than 14 point bold or smaller
than 18 point.
And for any text
that's above that,
we can go to our
contrast ratio of 3 to 1.
So I've got some examples here.
Over there on the
right-hand side,
you see some larger
text at the top
that satisfies that larger
contrast ratio, some smaller
text below that.
And then next to it,
you see some fields here
which aren't quite satisfying
that minimum ratio.
And even for folks
in this room, I'm
imagining that these
other fields, over here,
are a little difficult
to read, right?
And so there's a
number of good tools
that we can use, as we're
doing our design process,
to make sure we are nailing
those contrast ratios.
So material design team have
made a very nice color palette
tool.
You can go through, you
can pick some colors.
It'll actually lay them out
a little bit in your design.
But what I think
is really awesome
is this accessibility
tab, which will show you
when it's safe to use
either light text or dark
text on that background color.
It'll throw little
warning signals at you
to indicate, hey, you
maybe can't use dark text
on this particular background.
And it'll also indicate
minimum opacity levels
that are safe for your text
and that satisfy those contrast
requirements.
And you can also go in and
drop in your own hex values,
as well.
Another tool that
I use all the time
is this contrast ratio
tool by Lea Verou.
This is great for doing quick
spot checks in your app.
You just drop a background
color in, a foreground color,
and it'll tell you
the contrast ratio.
So you can very quickly identify
whether you're on the bubble,
maybe you just need to tweak it
a little bit, or if things are
way off and you've got to
go back and really address
your color palette.
Once you've get your
colors squared away,
the next thing is to
tackle your tab order.
So what do I mean by that?
So your tab order is the
order in which elements
are going to receive focus as
the user's pressing the Tab
key on their keyboard.
And ideally, your
tab order should
be flowing from the top of
the page down to the bottom,
starting in the top
left, flowing down
on the bottom right.
And we want it to follow the
visual layout of the page.
And it's also nice if our
more important elements can
be higher up in the tab order.
So someone using a keyboard
primarily to navigate had
s more efficient experience.
They don't have to tab
through a million things
to get down to the
important controls,
like, add this item
to my shopping cart.
Something to note here
is-- so this is something
that a UX designer can
sit down that can actually
indicate all of the
interactive controls in a comp.
They can number
them to say, this
is the order and the
sequence that these things
should be focusable.
In general, you only
want interactive controls
to be part of your tab order.
You don't need to focus images
or headers or text, or anything
like that, just
stuff that a user
is going to interact with,
provide input to, something
like that.
And you can hand that
off to your developer
and make sure they
implement that.
Now, there's a very cool
tool called ChromeLens.
This is a Chrome extension.
And what it'll do
is, it'll actually
let you identify the
tab order in your site.
So I'll show you here.
You can trace your tab order.
And as I'm tabbing
through this experience,
it'll draw these
little red lines
to show me where the
focus was and the tab
order of this experience.
And so what you're
looking for is
something that's flowing down
the page in a nice fashion.
You definitely want
to avoid things
where it's like focus is
moving off screen and coming
back, or going to the bottom
of the page and back to the top
and bouncing around
like all bonkers.
So this is something you can
also hand off to your developer
and say, hey, this is
the flow that we're
going for in our experience.
Next is making sure
that your controls
have accessible labels.
And I consider this part
of the user experience,
so I consider this
something that
falls into the UX
designer's wheelhouse.
So the idea with this is,
particularly for controls
that we might not have
room to put text on screen,
I want to figure out what that
control is going to announce
for a screen reader user.
And there's a few
key rules here.
The first is that we want to be
succinct in the way we announce
these controls.
So it's very tedious to
listen to long descriptions
if you're using a screen reader,
so say as little as you can
that's still relevant
and super important.
You don't need to include
things like the control type
in the label, because
that will be announced.
If the developer is using
the correct element,
that should just be
announced implicitly.
Instead, what you
really want to do is,
you want to focus
on action verbs.
So when we're going
through and we're
identifying all the
controls on our page
and the label that
should be announced,
we want to do things like
say, hey, this button's going
to say "Search"
instead of "Magnifying
Glass," because "Magnifying
Glass" doesn't really
tell me anything.
"Search" tells me
the action that's
about to happen when I
click on that control
or interact with that
control using my keyboard.
So go through, and as you're
doing the comps for your page,
identify these
elements, figure out
what those labels should be,
and then you can hand that off
to your developer, who can
implement that using things
like ARIA.
Finally, I want to
make sure that I'm
providing multiple ways
to interact with my UI.
So in particular,
it's very easy to get
into the habit of just designing
for a mouse-only or mouse-first
interface and forget
that folks may
be interacting with your
controls using a keyboard.
And you need to plan all of the
various focus states that will
be appearing in your design.
So we've got a
drop-down widget here.
What's it going to look like
when someone's hitting the Up
and Down Arrow keys?
Even though it seems
like, yeah, of course
I would do that, I've worked
on a number of projects
where many of the focus
states were not thought out
by the designer in
the initial comps.
And then you have your
developer filling that in,
taking their best guess of what
they think a focus state should
be for something.
So if this is something that can
go into the actual initial UX
design of the
project, that makes
it a lot easier for everybody.
And another thing
to keep in mind
is that you want to avoid
conveying information using
only one modality.
So consider multiple ways
of conveying information
to the users.
So if I'm doing something
like validation--
the example over here that's
just the red underline,
if I'm a user with a
color vision deficiency,
I might miss that as
being an invalid state.
So if we use multiple modalities
for conveying information,
we have the red underline
plus some helper
text to tell the user, hey,
something's wrong here,
then we're more likely to cover
our bases better and make sure
that the user does get that
information conveyed to them.
All right, so these are my
big items for the designer
to keep in mind-- making
sure they've got good color
contrast, tab order and
labeling is well-identified--
you can hand that off
to your developer--
and that you're
making sure you're
planning for multiple ways to
interact with and understand
the content on your site.
Finally, we've
got our developer.
And the idea with
the developer is,
they're managing a
few different things.
They're handling
focus in the page,
they're handling
semantics, and they're
handling good CSS styles.
And we're combining
all this stuff together
to create a really
nice, robust experience.
I'm a front-end developer,
primarily, by trade.
So while everybody else
got four checklist items,
the developer gets six.
So I'm just more
familiar with that.
So making sure we've
got a good tab order,
we're managing focus properly,
we've got good keyboard support
throughout, we're using
ARIA and other things
to convey semantics
where needed,
and that finally, because
being lazy is good,
we are automating as much
of our process as possible.
So let me dive
into each of these,
starting with the tab order.
So the designer
hands us that comp
and says, hey, this is
the order that I want
things to flow in the document.
Cool, how do we
actually implement that?
There's a number
of HTML elements
that you work with
every day that
are implicitly in
the focus order--
so button, input, select.
Anyone can hit Tab,
land on these controls,
and they have built-in keyboard
support, which is great.
So wherever possible,
using native controls
is going to get us a long way
towards nailing that good tab
order.
It's also important to note,
though, that not every element
is focusable.
So images and
paragraphs, divs, spans--
these elements are not
automatically opted
into the tab order.
And so problems arise when we
use those elements to build
custom controls and we
don't do the extra work
needed to add proper
keyboard support to them.
So I'll show you
an example here.
This is one that I actually
took from a pretty popular UI
framework.
So this is your
classic hamburger menu,
responsive-design button thing
for opening your side nav.
And as implemented
right now, it's a div.
And so if you're watching
my focus indicator up
there as I'm trying to tab over
to that control, because it's
just a div, and
because, to the browser,
a div is just a generic
grouping element,
that element is not focusable.
And that means that a
user using a keyboard
is just never going to be
able to open that side nav.
And I see this on
a lot of websites.
The trick here is to
use the proper element.
Again, take advantage of
native HTML whenever you can,
because the platform is
trying to help you out
by doing implicit--
or opting elements
into the tab order for you.
So instead of a div,
we use a button.
A button is totally stylable.
It'll announce properly
to a screen reader.
And now, my user can just tab
over to that control and press
Spacebar, and it
opens the side nav.
Notice, I said Spacebar there.
So another side benefit of
using the button element
is, if you add a click
handler to it in JavaScript,
the button element has
this magical thing called
synthetic click activation.
So when you land on it and
you press Spacebar or Enter,
it'll actually run your
click handler for you.
So this is not something
that a div or a span
can do out of the box.
If you're making custom
controls with divs or span,
you've got to listen
for the keyboard event,
you've got to
check the key type.
And button's just
going to give you that
for free, which is really cool.
I'm so obsessed with
this that I actually
shot a video on it,
just called, "Just Use
button," because there's
a lot of other cool things
about buttons that I'm not
even talking about yet.
And I feel like developers
have forgotten this tag exist,
but it's super, super useful.
So yeah, shameless
self-promotion.
Go check out that YouTube video.
The next thing to
cover is making sure
that we're properly
managing focus
and that it's
visible in the app.
So what do I mean
by managing focus?
Basically, when you're changing
the content of the page,
it's important to
direct the user's focus
to that new content.
So for instance, if you're
opening a modal window
or you're sliding
up a notification
from the bottom of the screen,
or something like that,
if the user is using
a screen reader,
they may not get any indication
that, suddenly, there's
new content on screen.
But by directing focus
to that new content,
we can tell that user about it.
So I'll show you
an example here.
This is another pretty
common one that I see.
So here, I'm using
VoiceOver on mobile Safari,
which is an extremely common
mobile screen reader, OS combo.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to go click on that hamburger
menu button using my screen
reader.
So I double-tap to click on
it, it opens my side nav.
It looks like I'm
in the side nav,
but I'm actually still
in the hamburger menu.
And as I'm swiping, now I'm
just interacting with the links
behind the overlay,
which is not what
we want in our user experience.
But I see this on
sites all the time.
If you have not done
anything to direct
the user's focus
into that side nav,
they're behind the overlay.
They're interacting
with the page
when they probably shouldn't be.
So how do we fix this?
This is my implementation
for my side nav right now.
It's pretty simple.
What I can do is I can take
something like this header
element here, I can give it
a tabindex of negative 1,
which means it's
programmatically focusable.
So the user's not going to
reach it pressing the Tab
key on their keyboard, but
I can call its focus method,
I can direct focus
to this control.
So now I can listen for
the transition event
when my menu slides in, I
call focus on that control,
and now I've directed the
user's focus into that.
They can quickly get
to the navigation links
that they wanted
to interact with.
And I don't have them behind
the overlay, messing around
with the page when
they shouldn't be.
Another flip side
to this is sometimes
we actually want to retain
focus in a particular area.
We want to trap it.
We want to make sure that
it doesn't break out.
If you open a modal window, you
want the user to take action.
You don't want them
to accidentally end up
behind your overlay again.
And there are also situations
when you want to prevent focus
from entering an area.
So I'll show you
another example, again,
using the side nav, because
that's a very helpful example.
So I want you to watch
my focus indicator here.
And what's going
to happen is it's
going to start on
the hamburger button,
it'll disappear
for a little while,
and then it'll appear again
on this anchor tag on the page
that says "Click Me."
So what's happening is because
my side nav is off-screen
and it's full of
anchors, the user
is actually tabbing off-screen.
Focus is just moving
off-screen, and they're
interacting with things that's
not even visible on the page.
I see this on a lot
of websites, as well.
They'll have modal windows
that are in the DOM,
but are just
positioned off-screen
because they haven't
displayed them yet.
And they don't think the
user can get to them,
but they absolutely can
using their keyboard.
And someone using a screen
reader or someone navigating
primarily using their
keyboard, they're
hitting those
things all the time.
So we want to prevent
focus from going
into those off-screen elements.
There's a couple of
ways you can do this.
The most straightforward
is just to say, hey,
if something's
off-screen, I make
it display none or
visibility hidden.
Now it's not in the
accessibility tree,
now it's not in the tab order.
But I want to talk about another
method, which is something
that we're also
working on in Chrome,
and this is the new
inert attribute.
So this is a new,
global HTML attribute
that will remove an
element and its descendants
from the tab order and
the accessibility tree.
Now, let me show you
why this is useful.
So same scenario
here, except for,
this time, my nav has
an inert attribute
and my main body content
over there does not.
So I'm tabbing,
and my focus only
goes in between my main
content and the navigation bar
in case the user wants to
leave the site or something
like that.
That's totally cool.
We want to allow that.
But so far, this doesn't
really give me anything
different from display none.
Well, let's say the
drawer is open now.
OK, cool.
So we just move inert
to the main content.
So now, you can't interact with
the stuff behind the overlay,
but you can interact
with the nav.
In fact, you can only
interact with the nav.
So now the user is
tabbing through,
and they're only
interacting with the thing
that they should be
interacting with at that time.
So this is really
useful, for instance,
if you a modal window
that you just opened.
You direct the user focus
there, and you keep it there
until the user has taken
an action of some kind.
If you're interested in
playing around with inert,
we actually have a polyfill
for this up on GitHub.
So I'd love for folks to
try it out and tell us
what they think.
If it helps, if it
hurts, let us know.
And hopefully, we're going to
try and ship this behind a flag
in Chrome very soon.
The other key point
here is making sure
that we're managing focus
and that it's visible.
So this is another issue
that I see on a lot of sites.
Focus rings, or
focus indicators,
in CSS, that can be a tough
situation sometimes, because it
often feels like the browser
is displaying focus rings
in a very haphazard
fashion, so to speak.
So I'll show you
an example here.
I've got an input
text field, I've
got a regular native
button, and then
I've got a button element that
I've just styled to look fancy.
We'll say that's
our fancy button.
So when I go and I click
these different controls,
you can see that the
focus ring behavior
is different for each one.
So I see a focus
ring on the input,
I don't see it on
the native button,
and I do see it on
my fancy button,
even though it's
the same element.
Well, that's weird.
And I see that a lot
of developers hit this,
and they're like, I wasn't
expecting that blue focus ring
on that last control.
They go to Stack Overflow.
They're like, how do I
get rid of the focus ring?
And then someone's like, oh,
you just say, "outline none,"
and you just remove all of them.
And this is a huge anti-pattern.
Please do not do this.
Again, remember, if
someone's navigating
with a keyboard, the
focus ring, that's
like their mouse pointer.
And if that thing
goes away, it'd
be like if I took your
mouse pointer away.
And you'd be like, I don't know
what I'm about to click on.
So we want to avoid
that situation.
But I also understand
why it happens,
because it seems inconsistent
with what's going on here.
So to help with this, we're
working on a new CSS selector.
This has actually just landed
in CSS selectors level four.
It's called focus-ring.
It's a pseudo class.
And focus-ring, today, will
help differentiate between mouse
and keyboard focus.
And the way that it works is it
matches whenever an element has
focus, and based on an
underlying browser heuristic,
the browser has decided it
should draw a focus ring.
OK, what does that mean?
Today, it means the
underlying browser here
so just basically says, the
user's using a keyboard.
So focus matches,
and I've determined
the user is using a keyboard.
Well, there's a
lot of cool things
that we can do now that
we have the opportunity
to opt into this heuristic.
For instance, a site,
or maybe Chrome itself,
could expose a user preference,
that someone could say,
you know what, I always want to
see focus rings on everything
that I click on.
It helps me keep my context.
It keeps me from getting
lost on the page.
I'm going to check that
as user preference.
Cool.
OK, we'll just say that you now
have opted into the heuristic,
and focus-ring will match.
So there's a cool
opportunity here
to start allowing
users to customize
the experience for how
they see focus indicators.
So thinking about
that fancy button
that I was showing there,
we could do something
like this, where we
could say, all right,
let's override the
default focus style,
because it's being
applied haphazardly.
And instead, we'll make sure
we create an indicator for when
focus-ring matches.
So what that allows
us to do, then,
is as the user is
clicking with their mouse
between these
different elements,
we get consistent behavior
between our two buttons.
And when they're tabbing
through with a keyboard,
we now have the focus indicator
on all of our controls.
So this helps us differentiate
mouse and keyboard focus,
and we get a more
consistent feel to our app.
We also have a
polyfill for focus-ring
that is also up on GitHub.
So we'd love for folks to try
that out, as well, and let
us know what they think.
Yeah, any feedback here,
greatly appreciated.
Next, we want to talk about how
we give interactive elements
good keyboard support.
So when I was first
getting into accessibility,
I would build a custom
control, and then I'd
be like, I'm not
quite sure everything
I need to add to this
control to make sure I can
say it's keyboard accessible.
What's supposed to happen when
you hit different arrow keys?
I felt like I was guessing.
And I discovered this
awesome document.
And it doesn't look like
an awesome document--
it looks like a
boring document--
but this is an
awesome document, OK?
So this is the ARIA
Authoring Practices Guide.
Yeah, I know it has the
classic spec look that
makes every developer
just fall asleep.
But what this does is it
lists a bunch of UI patterns.
And you can pick a UI pattern,
and it'll take you to a section
where it will just tell
you the expected keyboard
support for that UI pattern.
So if you're building
a radio group,
it'll say, OK, cool, when the
user presses the Down Arrow,
this is what should happen.
When they press the Spacebar,
When they press the Home
key or the End key--
some of those keys that we
sometimes overlook or forget
about--
this is what should happen.
So this is your cheat sheet
to component accessibility.
I love this doc so much.
If you take nothing
else from this talk,
ARIA Authoring Practices
Guide-- yes, take that with you.
A pattern that I use a lot
when I'm implementing these
is called roving tabindex.
So roving tabindex is a
good way to manage the focus
at the component level.
And the idea here is--
let's say we're
building a list box.
We might have 100
items in that list box,
and it would be very
annoying for the user
to have to tab
through every item.
So instead, we want
the entire control
just to be one tab stop.
When the user lands on it, if
they want to interact with it,
they can hit the
Up and Down Arrow
key, or something like that.
And so to handle those arrow
key presses, what we can do is,
we can give every child here
a tabindex of negative 1,
except for the
currently active child.
We'll give that one
a tabindex of 0,
which means it's in the
natural keyboard tabbing order.
So someone tabbing will
tab to this control.
They'll just land
right on that element.
If they press the Down Arrow
key, we'll listen for that,
and we'll just say,
oh, cool, I'll just
move tabindex 0
to the next child
and I'll call focus on it.
And now, if they tab
out of the control
and they Shift-Tab
back in, they're
going to land right back on
the previous active item.
So this is actually how I
implement keyboard support
in almost all of my controls.
I'm just listening for
certain arrow keys,
I just find the child that
tabindex needs to move to,
and I call focus on it.
It's that straightforward.
I actually shot a video on
this, if you're interested.
I do this show on YouTube every
two weeks called "a11ycasts."
I should have maybe
mentioned that before.
But yeah, so we have an
episode on roving tabindex
and how to build
your own radio group.
If you're interested
in that, as well,
definitely go check that out.
All right, cool.
So we've got keyboard
support squared away.
The next thing is making
sure we've got good ARIA
support in our custom
controls that we're building,
making sure that they're
being announced properly
by a user who's using
assistive technology.
So again, the ARIA
Authoring Practices Guide--
this is why I love
this document so much--
it'll also, obviously,
as the name implies,
tell you what ARIA attributes
and rules and states to apply
and when to apply them.
So going back to that doc,
if we're building a checkbox,
it'll just say, OK, cool,
you're building a checkbox?
It's got to have
rule equals checkbox.
It's got to have aria-checked
equals true or false,
depending on its state.
It needs to have a label
via aria-labelledby,
and we'll talk about how that
works a little bit later.
But again, this is
just your cheat sheet.
You go there-- if
you're new accessibility
or you're just building
some components
and you want to make sure
they're good, solid components,
check them against the Authoring
Practices Guide patterns,
make sure you're implementing
all of this stuff,
and have a much happier time.
So yeah, I mentioned
aria-labelledby.
I want to talk about how
we label these controls,
because labeling is
super, super important.
Basically, labeling
of our controls
helps the user really
understand the purpose
of that particular
control, what's
about to happen when
they interact with it.
And there's a few ways that
we can go about doing this.
If you are familiar with the
label element, which we often
use inside of forms, that is
a good way to label controls.
It primarily works just on form
elements, like input, select,
button, things like that.
So it's not going to help us if
we're building custom controls,
like a web component or
something that hasn't existed
in the browser
before, but if you're
using any sort of built-in form
element, this is a great tool.
So you can wrap
an element in it,
you can reference an element,
using the for attribute
of the label element.
And then, up there
at the top, in green,
I've got some text that my
screen reader would announce.
So in this case, I'm
wrapping this input element.
And my screen reader,
when it lands on it,
is going to say, "First
name, edit text."
Cool.
All right, so this helps us if
we're using some native form
inputs, but what if we're
doing something else?
Maybe we don't have a place
to display text on screen.
So the hamburger menu--
great example of this.
And I see a lot of websites
which don't do this.
And so you land on that
thing using a screen reader,
and it just says, "button."
And I'm not inclined to
click on a button that
just says "button" and
nothing else, because that
could be the send you my
social security number button.
So I'm not going to press that.
So what we can do when we have
a control where there isn't
a place to put text on
screen is we can give it
its own little text alternative,
using the aria-label attribute.
So this will override any
default labeling mechanism
this control might have.
It just allows us to create
a good text replacement.
So for our hamburger
menu, we can just give it
an aria-label of main menu.
If the user lands on that
using a screen reader,
it says, "Main menu, button."
Awesome, we know what
we're interacting with.
Finally, we've got
aria-labelledby.
So this one's
pretty interesting.
It basically lets an element
point at another element
and say, hey, that
element over there,
that element provides my label.
So an example would be, I have
a button that says, "Shop Now."
And if a user lands on
that, it says, "Shop Now."
It's like, well, OK, but
which section of the store
am I going to?
If we want, we can
take that header
up there that says
"Men's Outerwear,"
we can use aria-labelledby
on our button,
and we can point at
not only that element,
but we can even
point at ourselves.
You can actually have these
compound aria-labelledbys
just by pointing to multiple
space-separated IDs,
and you can build
this composite label.
So I'm saying now, when
I land on that button,
it says "Men's Outerwear,
Shop Now, button."
Cool.
So these are some useful tools.
When you're building
custom controls,
make sure you're labeling
them, so that way, the user's
understanding the purpose of
that particular input widget
that they're working with.
Finally, you're
doing all this work,
you want to make sure
that you're not regressing
and missing errors,
or perhaps overlooking
a part of your site.
So this is where automation is
really going to help us out.
So there's a number
of really great tools
that will make it easier for you
to catch accessibility errors
and fix them.
One that I really like is a
tool called aXe by the folks
at Dequeue.
So it comes in various flavors.
There is axe-core,
the node module.
There's axe-cli, which you can
just run from your terminal
and point at a URL.
They have examples on using
aXe with Selenium WebDriver.
Really, really cool
library, so definitely go
check that out on GitHub--
super useful.
And this is the kind of
thing which, if you recall,
I was talking about having
an accessibility checklist
earlier.
This is the sort
of thing where you
can use that with your
checklist to automate
some of those checks.
So you don't have to
do everything manually,
which is very helpful.
Some of you may have also seen a
project that we are working on,
called Lighthouse.
So this is for auditing
a Progressive Web App,
making sure it's performant and
doing all the best practices.
Under the hood, Lighthouse
actually relies on axe-core.
So when we generate
a report for you,
we have an
accessibility section.
We're going to hop down
there, and the tests
that we're exposing
here are the ones
that we're leveraging
the aXe library.
So if you're already
using Lighthouse today,
you're already using aXe,
which is really cool.
And you can do something like
this to get a report card,
get a little score, and
figure out, roughly,
where you stand with
accessibility in your existing
project.
And finally, for
spot-checking things,
it can be very tedious to have
to turn on your screen reader
every time you want to check
just a particular control
or see if changing
something is fixing it.
So we're actually working
on some experimental, new
accessibility DevTools.
So these are available in
Chrome today behind a flag.
So you can go into
chrome://flags/#enable devtools
experiments.
I'll also make these slides
available after the talks.
You don't have to write
all these URLs down.
But you can go here, turn on
Developer Tools Experiments.
You'll have to restart Chrome.
You go to your DevTools,
you go to the Settings,
and you go to the
Experiments tab.
You enable Accessibility
Inspection,
and then you can
actually just go look
at nodes in your Elements panel.
And along with your styles
and your computer properties
and everything, we now have
an Accessibility Inspector
that'll tell you whether your
element has proper labeling
or not, or what the screen
reader is about to announce.
It shows you the name
computation algorithm,
which is really helpful.
It tells you the ARIA role, the
ARIA states that are currently
applied to your elements,
so you can identify
if you've got any issues there.
Yeah, super useful stuff.
So yeah, this is my checklist
for the developer-- logical tab
order, properly managing focus,
good keyboard and ARIA support,
and automate as much as
you can to catch any errors
or regressions.
So wrapping up, again, I
want to remind everyone,
accessibly is a team effort.
It's really, really
difficult if you only
have one person doing
this on your team.
It's so much better when
everybody is bought in,
everybody has some
fundamentals and is
able to contribute
to this together.
These are, again, the high-level
goals for each of these folks.
I want the Project
Manager to make sure
that they're training the
team, that everyone has time
to learn about this topic, that
you're identifying your use
cases, that you're
incorporating a good checklist.
Your Designer is understanding
the needs of the users
and making sure that they're
designing inclusively.
And that your Developer is
managing focus, managing focus
indicators, got good
keyboard support,
and you're handling
your semantics
through things like ARIA.
Again, quick refresh some
of the resources-- we
have our accessibility course.
This is on Udacity today.
It is a free, multi-week
course at bit.ly/web-a11y.
My YouTube series, "a11ycasts,"
if you want to check this out,
comes out fortnightly,
every two weeks.
We talk about not only
accessibility fundamentals,
but also the cool stuff, the
bleeding-edge stuff, the hip,
new specs and standards, and
what's around the corner.
Also, check out our guides
on web fundamentals.
And check out the material
design guidelines, as well.
I think this is a really, really
good resource for designers.
With that, I just want
to say, thank you so
much for being with me today.
And I hope you enjoy the rest
of your time here at I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]